there are certain counter-strike clips
that are so iconic that most of us can
recite them word for word
Smith's looking confusing these are
timeless unforgettable calls that have
come to embody the very soul of this
beautiful storied franchise sometimes
they make you die with laughter other
times they make you want to stand up and
scream
and then there are the occasional
call-outs that send shivers down your
spine Kenny you know one versus three
and luminosity they are one round away
from match and mappoint here Kenny alien
single headshot he's got the double
sprays gets one more there is no goddamn
way that he's gonna do this
he's got no help gonna go break oh my
god but what if I told you that some of
CSS most revered soundbites weren't
created by its most reputed casters or
competitors but by its single most
recognizable rager but some of the
game's most celebrated moments were in
fact moments I can kill miniature just
believe in me right now all right by the
way he hasn't been flashed at all all
the pressures on me boy this is it this
is it meet the always animated Muhammad
mo Asad a retired professional CS player
who over the years has solidified
himself as one of his game's biggest
celebrities how well by being the
shrillest what the whiniest and angriest
streamer counter-strike has ever seen
where site site site bro site call it is
so how exactly did mo manage to become
one of the biggest cultural icons in
counter-strike and how has his very
particular approach to content creation
changed the streaming landscape forever
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
[Music]
that's what you did
okay so if you're even remotely familiar
with Counter Strike or have watched
literally any of our top 10s you've
probably encountered the indignant and
infuriated a man-child that is Moe but
[ __ ] go these days
Moe is known as a self commercialised
rager who counterbalances his csgo
obsession with his undying love of
supercars sketchy gambling sites and his
ever so supportive family no but before
his live-streaming stardom Moe was
making a name for himself in CS source
as part of the first wave of North
American pro players
he even famously participated in the
catastrophic [ __ ] show that was the
championship gaming series worden as he
moved up to the bomb site he decided to
go in for the plant and even nails it
gets nailed by Moe now like Moe the CGS
was noisy in-your-face and well a little
over the top
[Applause]
CGS was a veritable disaster from a
financial standpoint yielding an
absurdly low return on a ridiculous
investment not like anything we'd ever
see in eSports today
nope anyway following the collapse of
CGS in 2008 source really struggled from
an eSports perspective with everyone
returning to 1.6 Moe was only able to
attend a handful of tournaments a year
it wasn't until the advent of global
Offensive that he found a new way to
make his mark I'm watching ups that was
middle he was middle like a lot of his
regions so-called elite Moe wasn't able
to find a great deal of success in csgo
so after nearly three years of hopping
from roster to roster he began to devote
his full attention to streaming now from
the get-go it was clear that Moe wasn't
your everyday retired Pro sure he was
fostering up-and-coming talent but try
as he might he couldn't always keep up
with that talent it quickly became
apparent that he's blossomed into a
unique type of entertainer not the kind
you'd expect to dumster people but a
performer whose misery became the source
of your delight
well done fuck-all them hey what's wrong
what do you want what do you want what
do you want what what I mean if I you
know I'm streaming what do you want
before long mo began to cement himself
as csgo is most recognizable rager the
one who all of the top talent loved to
intentionally piss off but you [ __ ]
[ __ ] virgins just play seriously what
the [ __ ] okay I'm being trolled this
isn't even funny shut the [ __ ] up
this might be the best way to describe
mo most most like a car crash like you
don't actually necessarily want to see
it but you can't really stop yourself
you're watching him because you want to
see the crash you're watching it because
you want to see the insanity and more
often than not he delivers he is just a
funny funny guy he's got an incredible
like amount of of charisma to him he's
got an incredible like a I guess gravity
but not in like the serious sense like
you know he is he just says he has that
ability to attract all the attention
into his direction whether you're poking
fun at him he's willing to take the
jokes and he's in he's got this
incredible ability to like deflect the
insult and turn it into something funny
whether it was the whining the whiffed
shots or the wails that ensued mo had
begun to cultivate a brand of sorts here
you had this washed-up warrior who
wasn't just trying to keep up with the
kids but capitalizing on his inability
to do so the result was a so-called
moment oh my god in a second headshot
chicken coop chicken coop chicken coop
still no person
please please chicken coop chicken coop
chicken coop don't work do you play have
you ever played this map before please
please don't ever play this map again
and Varon lay the secret to most success
see before streaming was what it is
today with ragers rearing their heads
left and right constantly trying to
one-up each other no one had really
invested in their own fury and
indignation the way that moated dead-ass
the dude was kind of a pioneer he was
one of the first people I knew that was
like actually making ridiculous money
streaming in my experience and from what
I saw mo was just the first one who
showed that you could get away with
being a flaming [ __ ] he was he was
the first one who showed me that you
know if you you can't have those rage
streams and you can have you know all
these clips of you just being a complete
[ __ ] to two other players so
complete people but if you if you're
funny while you're doing it you know
everyone focused on the funny side of
[Music]
now part of the reason for Mo's
explosive and sustained popularity is
the fact that in addition to being an
enduring and adored title counter-strike
is very difficult
it's also a literal [ __ ] of a
video game capable of evoking some of
the most visceral reactions in eSports
so on some level there was an almost
spiritual need for a streamer like mow
one who both casuals and he and
competitors could identify with hundred
percent there's a boost here look look
100 percent look look there's blog on
both walls you've got stop boosting stop
it
we're trying to win god dammit he wasn't
just an entertainer he was a mood a
personality that literally every person
ever to play counter-strike could tune
into and feel see
that's I think that if that is part of
the hilariousness is like how it does
kind of culminate like the traditional
experience of people playing Counter
Strike mo is is so frustrated and it's
normally with such every kind of every
matchmake day happening things that
someone's not calling the spot where
they're at someone sort of flash without
calling it someone get mo gets shot in
the back where Sona supposed to be
watching and he just loses [ __ ] and I
think everyone can just kind of relate
on some level so those are the best
moments the moments at some point it
became clear that people would watch
this dude screw the pooch while doing
pretty much anything so he decided to
run with it
expanding his repertoire of rage to
gambling please physical activity and
family life the problem of course is
that once you start exploiting your own
unbridled fury to rake in the views it
can be hard to keep it in check
sometimes mo could get a little too
toxic come to me cuz you don't know this
is under it right here you don't get
spammed right here under it rise right
now that's not the spot he brought you
dumb [ __ ] and other times he was just a
straight-up [ __ ] just see the first
10 years of the last day no [ __ ] your
parents no no really
Tim [ __ ] your parents legit I'm Thai
right now [ __ ] your mom [ __ ] your dad it
was no secret that over the years the
skill gap between MO and the
up-and-comers he'd helped Shepherd into
the scene had really started to widen
he'd become so focused on raging that he
lost his edge and
become kind of a laughingstock which
gave him an ax to grind you think mark
is a [ __ ] genius Turk I'm on top of
the [ __ ] score bro don't talk [ __ ]
all right
nine points what's your points you ran
up in and died you're proud of yourself
an out you helped a lot because I mean
yeah that was because of you that was
Kezia too that was cause you on the
surface mo might have appeared to be a
community joke but the truth is he was
the one laughing all the way to the bank
you see mo was able to recognize that
this character and brand that he was
building was actually going to open a
lot of doors for him
he'd become such a known figure within
the scene that echo fox entrusted him
with the responsibility of building
their csgo roster hell even eleague was
convinced to bring him in as a desk
analyst which went about as well as
could be expected they messed up a lot
of rounds but the crucial rounds were
lost because of Trista he simply does
not know how to rotate on this map at
all every time they had the man
advantage he gave it right back by doing
some idiotic rotate that I do not
understand why there's literally no
reason for what he did but he did it
round after round see that's the thing
about mo sometimes he's known for taking
his shtick too far and every now and
then he has been involved in controversy
and been rightly called out for crossing
the line mo is on his most basic level
from what I can tell a very good guy and
a cool friend and a cool person to hang
out with he's a lot of fun it's also
done some very terrible things at some
point you want to just say most stop
being a [ __ ] idiot about this kind of
stuff but he keeps getting away with it
part of that is because he has an
incredible amount of charisma and I
think that's the real interesting part
about mo is I think there's a certain
level of people who are tapping into
this idea that he gets to break a lot of
the rules and he gets to recover from
situations where other people wouldn't
recover but I think people like to watch
the fact that someone gets to be the
[ __ ] and gets to succeed and gets to
do some of the shady things and still
gets to move on leaving aside B's job
transgressions most faithfulness to his
identity has only further woven him into
the fabric of counter-strike what's more
mo has basically helped father an entire
genre of streaming in addition to paving
the way for some of Twitch's greatest
ragers he's managed to cultivate a
persona that never gets old
no matter the context I put to drop it
off right there okay thank you imma imma
[ __ ] do him a battery because at the
end of the day there's nothing like
watching somebody freak out over the
things you hate in the game Mo's ability
to commodify and transform his inner
rage into a lucrative brand reveals a
level of intelligence that is seriously
overlooked and whether you like him or
not his vision and endeavors have helped
to create a successful road map for
other streamers to follow for years to
come for better or for worse mo is as
much a part of the culture of
counter-strike as the culture of
counter-strike is a part of the MO
wherever it goes and however it evolved
he'll be there
losing his goddamn mind and let's not
kid ourselves we wouldn't have it any
other way mo run away Lauren away don't
come triple-dog no there were special
they wanna put too
hey the boys back I'm here with you nice
you know that the fact that they did
source in third person is [ __ ]
hilarious [ __ ] jerseys yeah we gotta
go we gotta go back straight up like
this is why I want to bake but this is
why we need like when I was doing this
bead I was like look I don't need to
realistically put this much about CGS
and most story but I was like it's so
off bTW it's so good like even just that
sound of that dude I just love the sound
of that dude [ __ ] standing up and his
[ __ ] air mattress oh well we got this
sweet mansion but CGS is the gift that
keeps on giving
it's so good it's just